koné internet est un moyen
extraordinaire de communication
planétaire sans frontières mais avec
tous les risques que cela comporte
informations mais aussi des informations
si de raciste antisémite pornographique
pédophile
une conférence est actuellement réunis à
paris pour tenter de mettre des
barrières d'édicter les règles
pas facile yann gicquel sylvain de voix
sur internet la haine sans frontières se
propage à la vitesse de la lumière
racistes antisémites négationnistes ont
trouvé là une tribune planétaire depuis
hier à paris l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
rassemble 55 pays pour tenter de
concilier liberté d'expression et
contrôle de l'information
le but de cette réunion trouver des
points communs aux législations
contradictoire sous peu dans certains
pays répressifs dans d'autres comme la
france a aujourd'hui véritablement de
consensus sur la mise en place d'un
cadre juridique contraignant commun à
tous les pays et les pays étrangers
pourront s'inspirer de la france qui
vient de se doter d'une loi définissant
le cadre des responsabilités peut pas
demander aux hébergeurs de connaître et
donc d'être responsable de tout ce
qu'ils hébergent
c'est pour ça que la nouvelle loi a
décidé qu'il n'était responsable que
lorsqu'ils avaient été informées et ce à
n'importe qui peut les informer de ce
qu'un contenu du site se situe sur tel
ou tel site
seulement voilà s'attaquer aux 6000
sites racistes répertoriés pour la
plupart hébergés aux états unis ce
serait touché au premier amendement de
la constitution américaine garantissant
la liberté d'opinion et d'expression et
du côté de la maison blanche
on préfère en appeler à la
responsabilité des adultes
à compter sur moi comme je crois qu'on
peut faire beaucoup en s'assurant que
les parents apprennent à utiliser les
différents systèmes de filtrage
disponibles sur le marché et qui faisait
un oeil sur les pratiques de leurs
enfants
mais quelle que soit la sévérité des
législations les forums de discussion
responsable pratiquement incontrôlables
et les cyber des vies compris le
formidable tremplin
voilà on pour ce reportage